In order for us to plot vectors like this.
After having calculated their cosine similarity. We need
to talk about the polar coordinate system.
So let's first talk about.
The first prerequisite okay.
This is going to be about cosine.
similarities or similarity
And the polar coordinate system.
and this will be a foundation for
Other topics that we'll be covering this course, but later on even for differential equations
why differential equations, but because the prerequisite
for differential equations in particular partial differential
equations is complex analysis.
And you know in complex analysis we have these imaginary numbers.
And so we use the polar coordinate system extensively.
Okay.
anyway
Let's create a new section here called cosine.
alrighty
And the formula is this.
or side similarity
you would get the angle Theta and that's how you'll know how far these words
are apart from each other.
Let me show you how to do first calculate this with python and then how
to plot it.
So I'll return to vectors IP ymb.
And let me talk about the magnitude by the way.
So that's this term here in the denominator.
to calculate the magnitude is the square all the
components of the vector
add them all up and then take the square root of the sum.
So we get something that looks like this we will
first add up all the components of the vector. So let's say
the vector has components ABC and we'll
have
A squared again. We have an arrow over the a okay.
So these two are distinct are over Amy's Vector.
This is component of that Vector a squared plus b squared
plus c squared. F for example, this is
over R3.
And then we take the square root of this sum.
We're taking the magnitude for
both vectors
So how do we calculus and python?
Here, let me close this.
what I'm doing here is
enumerating
Or all the components in the vector v. So Visa vector
and we
denote X
Let me put x sub. I just to make it especially clear.
extra buys a component in v in the vector v
I'm going to import the math Library.
I will take every X
of Y of v and it raise it to the power too. So
this is the power method.
X is the base 2 is the power just like we saw earlier.
This will give us a list.
X sub 1 squared x sub 2 squared x sub 3 squared
and then we will use the sum function that's built into python to add
up all the elements in this set.
Once we have the sum.
Take the square root.
And that's of course how you calculate the magnitude?
To calculate cosine similarity of two vectors we do this.
Okay, this function will take two arguments two vectors.
First we have the numerator.
So we multiply these two vectors together.
and then the denominator
which is the product of
their magnitude
and then the return value of course is diffraction.
I'm going to go cosine similarity of
word Vector 1.
and would Vector 2
I run this.
It has a midst undefined we found this again.
that
we get well, it's almost one.
Let's look at the cosine similarity of Ward 1 and Ward 3.
I can see it's it's
it's smaller number.
So they are not relevant. What about word to
one word three?
Yeah, still not as high as these two.
Now these are angles.
How do you plot these angles on?
a plot like
like that one. So, how can we visualize this?